So, let's let's go all the way over
there. Let's go see what's going on.
Zack, you ready to start? Uh mini Zack
is here.
What's Ooh, what's that again? Let's
hear that again. Maybe I misheard. Maybe
we misheard. Let's Let's hear it one
more time.
We will physically fight them here and
spiritually fight them.
This is one Ummah Sadaqah Jariyah video.
If you care about the dunya more than
the akhirah, skip it. By one donation,
you can help 1.8 million people in need.
551,000 people who've been fed through
the emergency food aid. You are going to
be sponsoring 4,200 orphans. You will be
helping 250,000 people in Gaza. You'll
be helping 123,000
people to be fed through our Qurbani
program. You will help feed 551,000
people through the emergency food aid.
56 masjids that are going to be built
around the world. And 74,000 given clean
safe water. That's why we want to keep
One Ummah 100% donation policy. And in
order for us to keep it 100, we need you
to help us by supporting this fund so
that all of the stuff that I mentioned,
you get the reward for every single one
of them. It's far more important than
the dunya. And you will see every penny
that you give on Yawm al-Qiyamah. The
decision is yours. The link is there.
Donate now. Assalamualaikum
warahmatullahi wabarakatuh brothers and
sisters and dear friends. Hope you guys
are well, inshallah. And hope everyone
is doing well. Assalamualaikum. Wa
alaykumu s-salam wa rahmatullahi. How
you doing? I'm good, man. Crazy night.
Crazy night last night.
>> It's a beautiful welcome in London, man.
I told you the people here are more
receptive. They're more respectful. I
thought you was giving that feedback on
the Yeah, [clears throat] yeah. So,
British people, in my opinion, have been
very nice. This is my personal
experience of only been here for a
couple of days so far. Two three days.
Very nice. And subhanallah, yesterday,
the dawah was going very well. Are you
sure you wasn't being aggressive to
these people?
>> No, not at all. You sure? You like
>> No, you could check the clips. Check the
clips and the audio.
>> you? No. You know what? Let's watch the
clips. Let's see cuz you had about five
people there.
>> Let's take a Let's take a look. You'll
see.
>> the mood was before the instigators
came. All right. Just check yourself,
guys, inshallah.
Lovely to meet you, AJ.
>> Thank you so much. What was your name
again?
>> Dylan. Dylan.
Dylan and Max. Nice to meet you. Nice to
meet you. Thank you guys for the lovely
conversation. Have a good one. Enjoy the
rest of your night. Bye-bye. Have a good
one. Have a good one.
friends in the world. Have a good one,
my man.
Nice to meet you. Have a good one, okay?
Enjoy your day.
Okay, that's it, my brother.
>> back to you one day.
>> What's your name? Ovarious. Ovarious.
Nice to meet you, man. I'll come back
with knowledge one day. We can continue
talking. Make sure you look into it, all
right? Thank you. Have a good night.
Enjoy your night. Enjoy. Have a good
one. Bye.
Nazarene.
AJ, thank you so much. I appreciate it.
If you have any other questions, you can
come here anytime, okay? Thank you. Have
a good one. Enjoy. Enjoy.
Talk. Promise. Promise. Promise. You
know where you're from? Nigeria? From
Belize. Oh, Congo. Nice, man. Nice. You
guys have a sick soccer team, man. It's
amazing. I appreciate it. AJ, nice to
meet you, brother. Anytime, just let me
know. Would you like a free Quran? Uh
I'm okay. Can I give you one? Yeah,
sure. Go ahead. All right.
Thank you.
It should be that. Yeah, absolutely.
Absolutely. I'm not going to take you
away from your friends too long, huh?
Have a good one. What I want to say
is to say
>> Yeah.
Are you a good man? Thank you. And help
me. Yeah.
Don't try and touch here.
You don't know [__]
Absolutely, man.
Thank you so much. Have a good one.
Enjoy your night. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That. Yeah, I've I've seen it all and
yeah, man. I've I'm around, man. I'm I'm
not I'm not a stranger. I've seen I've
seen. I appreciate you, man. Thank you
so much for coming. Have a good one.
Enjoy your day.
You got to try it, all right? Good to
meet you. Appreciate you, man.
Have a good one.
Pleasure to meet you guys.
Drake and Tim Hortons.
>> All right, man. Have a good one, man.
Enjoy your day.
Thank you. Have a good one. Enjoy your
night. Enjoy your night.
That's it. [laughter]
All right. Just look it up. Have a good
one, man. Have a good one.
Have a good one. Enjoy your day. Enjoy
your day.
Do stop by and usually they're not
recorded. So, do stop by and yeah, I
appreciate it. Have a great rest of your
night. Thank you. Have a good one.
Enjoy. Bye-bye.
Appreciate the conversation.
>> Thank you so much, man.
>> Good to see you. What's your name? AJ.
George. Nice to meet you. So, you guys
saw that, yeah? My multiple discussions
with atheists, Christians, agnostics,
Catholics, you name it. Male, female,
you name it.
Any trouble? Did the conversation end
any with disruptive someone us insulting
them They They insulting us us trying to
threaten them squaring up to them trying
to threaten them because they don't
accept our religion and we're going to
take their head off?
No. You saw that for yourself, correct?
Good. Okay. So, so far, alhamdulillah,
like you said, you had a good
feedback in the sense where the people
were receptive. Beautiful reactions.
Amazing reactions, yeah? And that is the
reason why they want to stop the dawah.
Yeah. Now, do you know why I stopped
going to Speakers' Corner? Why? For this
very reason. Because when you go there
and have an intellectual dialogue
discussion, they don't want that. So
much so in Speakers' Corner, I can
remember when we'll have a simple
dialogue with just someone who's there
as a tourist, Yeah. when they're about
to accept Islam, these Christians would
literally be waiting and they would come
and disrupt. Yeah. Don't accept It's
It's unbelievable. Instead of saying
preach the gospel, talk about Jesus,
talk about the good news. It's fine. We
have no problem with that. It's a place
where you preach your religion, we
preach our religion.
Nope. They instigate. They get physical.
That's one of the reason I stopped going
to Speakers' Corner because I've been
there for 11 about 10 years. And I
thought, you know what?
Hashim, Mansour, Smile 2 Jannah is doing
fantastic. The brothers are doing
fantastic job. They don't need me there.
You want to know what's so crazy,
though?
>> Yeah. Is that Chris I've interacted with
Chris. Actually, I just interacted with
Chris couple of months ago, I believe.
It was just me Mhm. on just on their
panel. So, I joined Inspiring
Philosophy's uh panel. Yeah. And it was
just a one v four. Dean Dean responds
was there with me as well. But he wasn't
talking much. It was just me against all
of them. Hold on. Hold on Hold on a
second, Libyano. Yeah. I mean, Chris
said clearly I mean, are you are you
lying here? Chris said [laughter] he's
been hunting you for 2 years now.
>> I haven't even been on YouTube for 2
years, all right?
>> Okay, maybe it's a different time. We'll
give Chris a good excuse. He's been
hunting you down for a debate. You're
telling me you had a debate with him? Uh
we already talked.
He didn't get to talk much, but the time
he spoke it didn't really go well for
>> Okay, you know what? I'm going to have
to ask evidence. Where's your evidence
that you had a debate with him? We we
could We could watch the clip. You ran
away from him for 2 years.
>> We could We could watch a small clip
here. So, you had a debate with him?
Yeah, we had we had a conversation. And
he he's not pursuing a debate with me,
either. So, I'm confused.
>> I've never I've never from my knowledge,
maybe he's done it somewhere, but he
from my knowledge, he's never said oh
Orthodox Muslim, I call you out to
debate. But when he came yesterday, he's
like, oh, you are a fat boy. You're
running from a debate. You've been
running for 2 years.
>> That's what I'm confused about. Who's
So, you Let me get this straight. Was
this a one-on-one debate?
Uh with Chris No, it was one v four.
So, even though one of [laughter] So,
you had a four v one and you debated all
of them? Yeah, yeah. It's It's on my
channel. You can check it out.
>> I think it's starting to make sense why
Chris pulled this maneuver. Yeah. Yes.
And by the way, let's make it clear
before we go into the videos and give
you guys actually what happened. We
condemn any kind of violence done
against anyone. We don't know what
happened cuz I moved away. But if it was
self-defense, we're going to let police
deal with that. If it was not
self-defense, we condemn that. Do you
condemn it? Yeah. I I already I already
said that on my Twitter. All right.
However, if this was not self-defense,
um we condemn it. If it was
self-defense, we'll let the legal
procedure take its course.
>> But all of that aside, right? Whether
it's self-defense, not self-defense,
that's something else. If you're there
and you're antagonizing con-
continuously and I'm telling you,
brother, I don't want to talk to you.
Which Which one do you want to run?
Which one
Who's running? I'm right here. I'm right
here, brother. Are you going to step up
to me?
Just like No, no, no, no, no.
Don't get close. Don't get close.
Don't get close.
Because clearly I see your behavior is
abnormal. And this is the point I was
going to say earlier, right? The guy is
actually not too bad of a person. Chris,
yeah, he gets a little filthy sometimes.
He's a blasphemer. But if you check his
interactions whether online and
Speakers' Corner, he's pretty cordial. I
I spoke to I spoke to you Yeah, he He
lets people talk. He talks back and
forth. But yesterday, and I you will see
I could smell alcohol Good. com- in his
breath. His breath stank, man. He was
all up in my face and he was very
aggressive.
>> Perfect. So, with Libyano, we're going
to come and dissect that in detail with
their footage, not our footage.
>> Yes. Yes. Before that, let's watch the
video of Libyano's interaction with him.
And now you're going to understand why
Chris has been really hurt and his
reputation has been so bad ruined so
badly that he had to pull this move.
Let's get some context of what happened
in the debate so you will understand why
Chris was upset.
>> Right.
Surah 4 ayah 171 makes it absolutely
clear. Describes Jesus as the word. This
term is a word Yeah, the word is
confirmed John 1:1. All right,
beautiful. Watch how I'm going to
destroy this guy cuz he is clueless.
>> Okay, do it. Do it. The Yeah, beautiful.
So, the concept of Jesus The concept of
Jesus being the word of God is confirmed
in Luke, not in John. Because Luke
>> What the presents Jesus as being the
word Stop. Why are you interrupting,
dude? Oh, no. I'm sorry.
I I do I get my words when I get
excited. Yeah, I know I know you're so
excited right now to get baited. So, the
word of God mo- The word of God Bro, be
quiet. I I think he's still getting
excited. I know. The word of God motif
The word of God motif in the Quran is a
Jewish word of God motif that's found in
Luke's narrative, not in John's
narrative. John's narrative is a middle
Platonic idea of the logos of God.
However, when we go to Luke's narrative,
we see that the word of God there is
similar to what the Quran sees Jesus as
being the word of God because Luke
speaks of Jesus as the word being
fulfilled to Mary. That's why Mary says,
"May your word be fulfilled to me." So,
when the angel comes to Mary, he gives
her a word and Mary says, "May that word
be fulfilled to me." Right. And that is
exactly why, let me finish, that is
exactly why the Quran intertext with
Luke's birth narrative in chapter Mary.
You have John the Baptist and Jesus,
John the Baptist's birth, Jesus's birth,
and you have that being contrasted with
Luke. So, now I don't have to Okay,
you're done. I know I'm landing, I
promise.
I don't have to concede
that the word of God motif comes from
John, the word of God motif comes from
Luke. So, you guys saw the shorts and
you played the video. Anything you would
like to say on that cuz it clearly seems
to be number one, you did have a debate
with him. Number two, there was no you
running away. And number three, I mean,
you did I mean, it did hurt it must have
hurt his ego a little And here's the
thing, right? This was on their platform
and it was just me talking to all of
them. No, Chris said No, hold on. Hey,
Chris and I said he ran away. Can I
speak? Don't let Chris run. No, you
don't WANT TO TALK TO ME ABOUT THAT.
HE'S a liar.
>> to talk to Chris just said So, tell us
Chris to shut his mouth if he doesn't
know what he's talking about. Chris just
said You need to shut your own mouth.
All right, so you say what is physical
Mind you, the plan initially was just me
and Dean were going to go talk to
Inspiring Philosophy and his butler
Thern, who I just exposed for being a
homosexual. Um by the way, I don't know
if you saw that. Uh so, uh he's hired,
he's an employee, Thern. He's hired by
um Inspiring Philosophy. Okay. And uh it
turns out he's sending inappropriate
pictures of his
um behind to kids on Discord. So,
[laughter] check that video. I would
Dave was by the the black guy, the Dave.
He's
>> Yeah, so they're all
And it's funny cuz he was making
comments saying, "Oh, you uh sleep with
uh [__] and stuff like that." I
don't know. It's an admission, I guess.
But um anyways, uh it was supposed to be
just us uh two on two, right?
And I show up and it's just four of them
and Chris is there for some reason.
Anyways, uh he wanted to talk about
Islamic dilemma cuz really that's all he
talks about. There's no He just wrote a
whole book on the Islamic dilemma. He
just talked He doesn't want to defend
Christianity. That's fine. We talked
about Islamic dilemma. He was all over
the place, confused. You guys will see
the video if you want to see the clips.
If you go on their channel because they
live streamed it, all the Christians in
the comments are saying, "This looks so
bad. Delete this." And that's why it
makes sense why Chris had to pull this
maneuver because the following day we
agreed to go speak at Speaker's Corner,
correct? Right.
>> Because we've got nothing to hide. And
with all due respect, to me it shows how
terrified they are of your arguments.
Because we was going to go speak at
Speaker's and Chris thought, "You know
what? Libyano's going to come for me.
He's already destroyed me online. If in
Speaker's Corner he goes up to me,
that's going to look really bad." So, he
thought, "You know what? I know, I will
pull up to him that I was looking for
him." Now, we're going to watch the
footage for ourselves inshallah brothers
and sisters.
Um and
Sorry, one second. We are going to watch
the footage from their side. This is
their footage of look at them
conspiring, watching us on our stream,
and look at if they are coming with
peace or hostility. Let's watch it for
ourselves and make you make your mind
up. And not only that, we caught them
actually admitting on audio. And this is
actually damning. You know why? Because
they actually talk about physical fight.
Yeah. Don't believe us?
The proof is in the pudding.
>> Watch the video.
Yeah, I've got my socks. We have Rev.
Camera over, please.
We have Rev. We have everyone here
basically, even even the Iceman Chris.
So,
>> [laughter]
>> Let's Let's go holler at them. Let's see
what's going on. All right. Oh man,
let's go.
There you go, Donald. Donald.
So, my advice is everyone's surrounding
them.
Okay, let's just hear that That's Chris
speaking in the back. Can you hear what
he's saying? My advice is let's surround
them. Surround him, I think he said.
Surround him.
>> seem hostile to you or is it peaceful to
surround him? In other words Yeah, so
sounds pretty hostile, man. Especially
with the context that we're about to
we're about to look at.
>> only that, funnily enough, you've got
Dave walking like he's challenging him
for debate. We want to know where Chris
is. One of the team members notices this
and says something.
Get in front, Chris.
Okay, here here one of one of the team
members notices this and says something.
Get in front, Chris. This is not making
sense. Why is Dave more adamant to meet
Libyano than Chris? So, he's like,
"Chris, can you go to the front, please?
Cuz I'm recording. This is going to be
embarrassing." [laughter] But it makes
sense because once you show me the video
Yeah. after what happened to him, I
would be apprehensive [clears throat] to
approach you. I'll be like, "You know
what? Let me send my little foot
soldier." And that's what it seemed
like. So, you can see even they're like,
"Chris, can you go to the front?"
>> honest, I didn't even realize that cuz
you know I was talking to that last guy.
>> Yeah.
I didn't realize that Chris was there.
He just showed up out of nowhere. I only
saw this this tall guy. What's his name?
David? Yeah, David. If you If you've
seen, I was speaking to them. I didn't
notice Chris just came from the left.
>> Yeah, I didn't see him either. Yeah, so
let's carry on.
So, you can see they are they are
literally the way he Dave is walking,
he's not there to have a little Look,
he's there for trouble. What happens
next? Now, listen very carefully. All
the what's been going on on X, let's
just quickly touch up on that. On X, as
you guys know, the narrative, poor
little Chris was just there to have a
dialogue and a debate, chasing him for 2
years. That's not the case because
what's been said said on X.
So, this is what Chris um from his
Twitter
says uh this has almost 100k views now.
So,
he says, "Last night in Leicester
Square, I challenged Orthodox Muslim to
debate the Islamic dilemma." Clearly, he
wasn't trying to debate. Yeah,
he refused and started name-calling. Who
was name-calling first?
>> to find out.
>> Yeah, we're going to find out. They were
They were name-calling us. So, they came
fat boy and all that all that stuff.
Anyways,
started name-calling while his
bodyguards got physical.
Finally, he got his best friend to
attack us. It was all recorded live.
Dawah is desperation. So, wow. So, so
that's one and then you had um David
Wood, you had him post the rat face.
>> Yeah, so this is what David Wood says.
He says, "This is Libyano's friend." He
posts some pictures.
Um
and he says that Libyano's scared to
debate. That's what So, that that's what
they're going with. That's the headline,
right?
>> [snorts]
>> So, what was Inspiring Philosophy
saying?
So, this is what he says. He says he
pulls posts a picture of his own friend,
bloody face,
>> Yeah.
for
50,000 people to see and he says Islam
causes violence. Well, we're going to
find out cuz we said clearly we condemn
any kind of violence towards anybody.
We've made that we're we're morally
consistent, not strategically. Again, if
it was done
out of like for example, no
self-defense, we condemn it. If it was
self-defense, we'll let the legal
procedure take its form. Now, let's see
if this is true because look, we're
going to hear for ourselves. Did anyone
from our side mention physical fighting?
Nada. Now, here listen carefully,
brothers and sisters. Look what they say
with their own footage about a physical
fight. You're about to be shocked and
David Wood and all of your propaganda is
going to go in the And this is before
anything happens. This is them talking
amongst each other before they approach
us. They're conspiring. They're
basically now
premeditated. So, this shows you what's
in their mind already before they even
come and approach us.
>> Exactly. We can see from the body
language of the way they're walking, the
way they're talking, etc. Now, the proof
is in the pudding. Watch this now.
>> [laughter]
>> So, you can see here they're calling me
for my real name. It's not a problem.
You know, everyone knows I'm not really
ashamed of that. Okay. They do it in
that They were even mentioning
my wife like, "Oh, you cheated on your
wife." They were this how personal they
were getting. So, I don't really
[clears throat] care. It doesn't really
phase me. Do you get what I'm trying to
say? It doesn't matter. But look what
they say now, guys. Listen carefully.
This is where
this is where it tells you who
instigated.
Chris. Ooh, one second. Let's hear that
again. Maybe I misheard. Maybe we
misheard. Let's Let's hear it one more
time just just to make sure.
>> where you see Allah always exposes,
guys. We're going to hear this one more
time. What did he say in the back, the
commentator?
We will physically fight them here and
spiritually fight them inaudible
somewhere else.
>> Something like that. Okay.
>> So, they want to physically fight us and
spiritually fight us. Okay, good. So,
now we don't mind both with all due
respect, but we're not there for that.
We're there to have a discussion,
academic discussion, and that's what it
is. And because you know you can't deal
with that, you came there saying what?
We didn't say nothing. Did you see
anywhere in our life where like,
"Listen, if they come, we will
physically fight them and spiritually
fight them." But I thought we were the
aggressors. I thought we were the
terrorists. I thought it's
Islam is violent. You can hear. This is
not AI. This is from their footage. We
are got We will physically fight them.
So, they came there for what?
>> this doesn't leave any room for
reinterpretation. Oh, what we meant was
spiritually. Because he actually
explains physically fight them and
spiritually fight them.
>> Unless they do a trinity on us and say
they are one in essence and it means all
kind of mumble jumble.
So, now you can see clearly that's what
happens. Now, they actually show us how
they wanted to do the physical fighting.
Look at how Chris approaches
Libyanu.
Look, if you notice, even caught me by
surprise. I didn't even know he was
coming from the left.
>> Yeah, I didn't see him either.
>> Now, just to be clear, we I have close
protection there. Because I get death
threats. I go to the table with a
knife-proof vest because of death
threats, okay? His job is there to
de-escalate. Now, if somebody comes
Look, if anyone If you're on the road,
bro, and I come to your face,
you're going to say, "Brother, move from
Why are you in my face?"
>> Personal space. Right. And And look at
the way he's coming. Look how close he
is to you, yeah? Okay.
Bro, so you can clearly see Does that
seem to you he's come there to challenge
you to a debate?
>> So, their their argument is, "Oh, well,
he had his hands in his pocket." I'm
Okay.
Does that mean that he can't step up to
me in a very aggressive manner and be
all up in my face? Cuz that's exactly
what he did. And like I mentioned
earlier, this was very surprising
because like I said, he's not known to
be like this. He's known to be cordial
and friendly most of the times. So, he
comes up. He's all up in my face. And
like uh uh brother Ali mentioned, the
guy there is just trying to de-escalate.
Why are you up in my face, my brother?
We could talk, but let's do it calmly.
And one thing I noticed, which adds on
to his fear of you, because number one,
you had a debate with him. Number two,
there was nothing hunting you for 2
years uh 2 years. Yeah. You smelled
what? Alcohol. Now, let me be honest
with you. I had one guy from Tommy
Robinson's friend, Sika. He came to me
with alcohol. Yeah. The reason they
drink alcohol is because they're very
nervous. Right.
>> Yes, okay. It's like when God Logic
showed
>> Gives you confidence.
>> Yes, the same with God Logic. If you saw
when God Logic came to my doubt table,
his whole demeanor changed when he saw
me. They have this innate fear. Yes? So,
when they come to you, they have to
drink something. Okay, maybe God Logic
was spiritually high. Okay? So, the
thing is what? Why do you need alcohol?
Because you said you smelled alcohol in
his breath.
>> Not only that, he was slurring his
words. You could You could If you watch
the whole thing
>> he seem like Chris?
No, that's
>> That's why I was very confused. I'm
like, "Brother, calm down." You'll And
you'll see in the video, I'm telling
him, "Relax. Calm down. It's okay. We
could talk." And he just kept repeating
himself. He He was You didn't even
understand what he said. And he was
slurring his words. So, clearly the guy
was drunk.
>> Yes. And what did the close protection
security do? He did his job. Look what
Let's watch for ourselves.
You know what I said? I said, "Are you
going to step up to me or something?"
Why? Cuz he's coming so close in my
personal space. Good. So, you can see
clearly that he just said, "Please
look." His job is what? That
Bro, you can stab him. He doesn't know
you. That guy doesn't know you. He's
like a group And by the way, there was
15 of them. They had flags as well. I
don't know what the flag was. There was
an A on it. I don't know what the flag
No, I didn't see it. Yeah, so they came,
15 of them. From our side, if you see
it, there was a lot of them. Now, what
we're going to do is This is where it
gets real
weird and bizarre. This guy, what's his
name? I don't know who he is. Uh Life.
So, this is a God Logic's butler /
boyfriend.
>> Um they have a history with these guys.
>> Yes. Yes. So, so, so, let's see what he
had to do because this guy used Chris so
badly. And he was sending people to
Patreon. And I couldn't believe somebody
who's on their side would tell you that.
>> Bro, bro, that's crazy. Let's see. This
is where you're going to understand who
started all of this, guys.
All right, guys. Today, I am minding my
own business. And then I get a text
message from Word telling me, "Yo,
Libyanu is in London and a fight just
broke out." Now, I just broke down this
whole video and I got a phone call from
David [music] and Chris to talk about
the situation. Just for you guys. And
one thing I want you guys to pay
attention and notice the gaslighting
>> [music]
>> in the conversation. The projection is
insane.
Notice how Libyanu was telling people to
calm down, aka when I say people,
Christians, of course, to calm down.
Interesting. So, a Christian is
admitting that you was telling people to
calm down.
>> down.
That's
>> And what did he say? He said he was
saying it to the Christians.
>> Right. So, who is the aggressor here
from the video footage we saw? The way
they're walking up to us. We will fight
them today. Right. To a Christian. Thank
you, Life. You know, I really appreciate
that. You know, the ongoing Thank you
very much. But let's carry on. But it's
a Muslim. His own Muslim brother. Their
own people was the one who issued and
initiated the physical attack first.
>> Which we're going to come to and we're
going to see. But let's carry on. Their
own Muslim brother that started this,
which led to this.
You see what he said? He said, "I'm not
a transgender." So, what he's trying to
say there is that I'm into trans cuz I
don't know where he got that from. He
said that I sleep with transgenders. And
wow.
>> Maybe he Maybe does that himself. I I
learned that That's a new thing I
learned about myself, I guess.
But yeah, so he's insulting first,
right? And I only I did insult him, of
course. And I only insulted him after he
started insulting me. Yeah. And if you
notice, as we mentioned, the night was
beautiful. So many beautiful
interactions.
All different kinds of people. And we
did even have some Christians come and
bother us a little bit, just randomly.
And we didn't think much of it.
Exactly. And you can see here you're
clearly repeating, "Calm down. Calm
down." Yeah. He's the one that's
insulting you, ad hominem, is calling
you name, etc. The way they walked, what
they were conspiring. We were saying,
"Listen, calm down. Calm down." Okay,
you can see clearly from the footage,
guys, who's instigating? There you go.
So, you can clearly see I genuinely
believe Chris is was really terrified
that you're in London and you might find
them and humiliate him again. So, he was
like, "Let's instigate this.
Make a hoo-ha." They were waiting for
someone to do that because they're
instigating. They knew, "If we was going
in a group towards a group of Christians
and instigate them, we're going to fight
them, they're all etc. And they hit us."
And we were like, "Oh, but you see what
happened." We're not buying it. No one's
buying it, with all due respect. Let's
see what happened next.
There you go. So, you are seeing
All you're seeing is calm down
conversation. Calm down conversation.
>> Can I tell you something?
>> Yeah. Uh the the way that I felt when I
was talking to these guys yesterday
was super like I've never felt that way
in my life. I've talked to many
Christians in person, off camera, on
camera, online.
The way that I felt yesterday was that
these guys were like demonic. Like they
were they were up to no good. And I
could sense that they were not there to
have conversations.
>> No. I keep telling him, "Brother, let's
talk. Let's just be calm, man." And he's
he's just losing his mind. And at one
point, I tell I end up telling the tall
guy, "I don't want to talk to you.
Bye-bye." Yeah. Yeah. In his face. Bye.
Can you leave now? Can you get out of
here? Yeah. And he just won't leave.
>> Yeah. And And And he Why would he not
leave when I told him to leave and I
don't want to talk to him? Cuz you know
why? They don't want that. And this is
the reason why we're going to make this
video. Number one, we've clarified.
You've seen who's started this. All
that's clear now.
Chris, you're not going to run away from
a debate. You are not going to use this.
We've seen it right through you. Again,
like I said before, condemn any kind of
violence to anyone for whatever reason,
unless it's self-defense, which we don't
know what happened. Chris, don't try to
run away. The debate challenge is still
there. So, don't you think you're going
to make all this hoo-ha and this
stabbing like, "Oh, I was going to
debate him." No, no, no, no, no. Chris,
Libyanu, are you up for a debate?
I'm always up for a debate. Um so, if he
wants to talk about the Islamic dilemma,
more than happy to do so. Dean already
handled that. You know, Dean had a
a formal debate with him. I don't know
if you know.
>> Yes. Yes. Yes. Um more than happy to do
it as well.
Um but one condition, because he always
He only talks about the Islamic dilemma.
So, my condition is that
I'll get to choose a topic as well to
talk to you about it and see how In a
controlled environment. In a controlled
environment without you coming up to me
like a hooligan, like a a thug, and
starting to, you know, cause drama and
trouble. So, if you're down for that,
I'm down for that.
>> Yeah. This not going Look, through this
video, we see right through you guys.
Yeah. The debate challenge is there.
Let's see what excuse you're going to
have. Yeah, what are you going to do?
Get another Muslim to pretend to attack
you so you can say, "Oh, no, I was going
No, no, no, no." The debate is there and
we will
love for you to come through. But let's
carry on watching, inshallah.
Okay, so something happened there we
can't see. There's this guy in front,
okay? We don't know what happened cuz
there's already tensions. And the
security trying to de-escalate the
situation. Something happens. Here is
the crux of the matter, guys. Because
you know what? Once that happened and
they've already been hostile and look,
they were
calling
bringing my wife into it, all this kind
of Yeah, because you can see what kind
of individuals they are.
Chris, in here this footage you'll see,
once this happening
Uzair, yes, and we're going to come to
your how you know Uzair later. Yeah. He
goes. He He's going. Then Chris is going
towards him. Let's see what happens
because this is where I you can make
your decision for yourself of what
happened there.
So, you can see he's been pushed, yeah?
Right.
>> He's been pushed. Okay. So, in that
situation, bro,
Uzair was pushed. So, from that
situation, I'm like, bro, you're pushing
me hostility. I don't know what
happened. I didn't see what happened,
yeah? Okay. Here it is where the the
physical fight happened.
Okay. I'm going to stop there.
>> other there. I'm going to stop here. I'm
going to take a screenshot as well,
yeah?
Now,
they're both coming at each other,
[clears throat] okay? Brother, if you're
pushing me, insulting me, calling him a
a a [__] or whatever it is for that
matter, Yeah, many racist remarks, by
the Many racist remarks, parents, family
brought into existence, whatever that's
happening, okay? Yeah. Now, you are
going towards him, both of you, and both
Chris and him are literally
trying to get one
on each other, okay? And I guess what
one of them wasn't quick enough, I
guess. I don't know. Exactly.
>> came to fight each other. That's what's
happening. So, you can see that's just
two people fighting, with all due
respect. And each one, Chris has a right
to come and say self-defense. Right.
Uzair, the brother I met yesterday, he
has a right to say self-defense. This is
what's occurred. But let's watch.
There you see. There you go. Yeah. Did
you Did you see that? Mhm. Okay, good.
So, now we're going to go to the next
footage, inshallah, of Mr. Live. As you
can see, David is livid, man. He wants
some more of that dude. I ain't going to
lie. When you watch something like this,
it just make you want to
I'm telling you it do. It do. But
>> Oh, wow. Okay, so you're admitting So,
one second.
>> One second. Okay, good. So, now he's
admitting, Mr. Live is admitting that if
somebody comes and instigates, and all
the footage that we showed you of them
instigating, we're going to fight them
here physically, and then spiritually
somewhere else, blah blah, what would
you do? He would do what? With his
little dead hooks. By the way, there
were some dead hooks here. I don't I
don't know what that was there, okay? I
don't know what he he was doing there,
okay? I think he tried to It was dead
hooks. So, what I'm going to say is
this, you've just admitted that if that
was to happen, there'll be physical
fight. Well, that's what just happened.
You came for trouble. We still didn't
want trouble. Let's talk. De-escalate.
Let's talk. What do you want? Can we
talk? Nada. You got into altercation
with a Muslim, okay?
We shouldn't be fighting, no. But at the
end of the day, if they started, you
know, don't start nothing and won't be
nothing. Don't I have to take his word?
Don't start nothing?
>> Not ours. Don't start nothing. It ain't
be nothing. So, whatever you said.
>> So, Mr. Live, are you going to hear He's
a [laughter] good commentator. I'm not
going to lie. I think I don't know if
he's being just here or his hatred, uh
you know, as
>> No, Live is all right, to be honest.
Most of the time he's all right. He just
hangs out with me.
>> I'm going to agree with him. He's doing
quite all right here. Yeah, okay. So, so
you've just admitted with your own
words, Yeah. and we've proved you who
instigated and started all of this. So,
to your
um
judgment, from our perspective, who
started it? They started it. So, there
you go. This is face
>> [music]
>> is leaking.
I'm talking about leaking leaking like
crazy. If y'all really want to see the
severity of this, click the link in the
description. [music] I'll post [__] on
my Patreon. Wow. No, you didn't,
brother. Brother,
>> Wow.
man.
>> Libyan I know he didn't, bro. Wow.
>> was doing so well. Yeah, man. Bro, he
was doing so well. I don't know what
happened. Let me Bro, let me just Bro,
this reputation is gone. Just imagine,
[laughter] bro. Bro, just imagine you
get into a fight. Yeah. You're bleeding.
Yeah. I do a video. And he posts it on
his YouTube.
>> And I And I post it on my No, no, no.
And I go And I go, "No, no, no, no. I
go, listen. Yeah, Libyan I got into a
fight, and he's bleeding."
>> You want to see the full image?
>> to see the full image?
Subscribe to my Patreon.
>> Brother, how embarrassing. How
humiliating. Are you that desperate,
Live? I don't know who you are. Okay,
right now, you should call yourself
Death, not even Live, because you just
killed yourself. My friend, you want to
put this on Patreon [laughter]
so people can see what really happened
to your boy?
Who's your loyalty with, money?
>> end here because Remember Remember when
he calls him?
>> He calls him.
>> He calls him. Let's see
>> worse. It gets worse.
The debate challenge is there, my
friend. Don't go anywhere. Let's watch
this now. Guys can see that, you know,
unblurred, but his face is
is is leaking like crazy.
>> even giving details. He's selling his
marketing, bro. Unblurred, leaking. Is
Is this Listen. Listen. He's He's
He's sold the Patreon, man. And not only
that, you know what we're going to say?
Bro, don't pay a penny. There's a free
version if you want to see it. We don't
want to see it. Right. But if you want
to see If you're so desperate to sell
out your friend like that, there's free
places you can go and see that without
paying this Live. Please, Live, yeah,
okay? You You just killed your own
reputation. I'm going to remember you
that for the like What He's your friend,
boy. And not only that, watch this phone
call.
Hey, what's up, Chris, man?
I'm over here seeing you seeing you all
bleeding on the on on YouTube, man.
What's going on, man?
Wow, man. What's go What's going on,
man? I just You're bleeding on my
YouTube, man. Bro, he's laughing.
Bro, bro, bro, bro.
>> that's Bro, I'll be honest, I feel I
feel a little bit bad when I saw Chris
there. Bro, I'm going to be like, "Hold
on a second. Yeah.
>> Libyan I Imagine I call Libyan I.
Yo, Aki, what's going on? You all right?
Yo, man, I just saw you your nose
bleeding. You look mash up, man. What's
happening, man?
>> What's happening, man?
>> Brother, you won't speak to me for the
rest of your life again?
Bro, is is this how desperate
>> just clicks and views for these guys.
>> Is this how desperate it's gone? And
here's the last clip, guys. This wraps
the whole thing up. And again, Chris,
the debate challenge is there. Don't you
dare try to use this as an excuse to run
away from Libyan I. Here where Let's
listen to Mr. Live's last commentary. We
got a problem. Yeah, Chris's nose is
clearly broken. I just want to throw
that out there. So, for you those of you
>> He keeps mentioning it. It's like she's
trying to incite people to buy the
Patreon. It's like God,
integrity, bro.
>> mentioning the nose, man. We got it. You
We Trust me, Dad. Live integrity, bro.
No logic. No logic. You're watching
this, man. Come on, I know you're
laughing. Actually, he was one of He was
one of the first ones to report.
Breaking news, the Orthodox Muslim and
God Logic. No logic, yeah? Yeah. Okay,
bro, bro, no logic. I know you're
watching this, and you're like I know
you're doing this like, "Damn, man. They
They They caught us bad." No logic. But
come on, man. Tell your boys to patten
up, bro. Come on, man. Using another
man's, you know, injury to get some
Patreon likes, etc. Well, actually, I
don't know if you if you saw, but
recently Logic got a little bit
aggressive
in Balboa Park. Oh, did he?
>> He got served.
What happened? So, Muslims served him.
They They're taking him to court.
>> Sheikh Osman Farooq's table. Yeah, yeah.
So, he went there. Sheikh Osman wasn't
there, but he got a little bit
aggressive. Yeah. Um and uh yeah, he put
his hands on a on a brother. And then
what happened? Uh it was something about
his wife or so I I don't know exactly
what happened, but yeah, he got a little
bit aggressive, so. But did he get
stopped up [clears throat] or
Uh no, no, no. No. So, he he got a
little bit aggressive, but the situation
de-escalated quick. And And I tell I
promise you, he's going to become like
David Wood. Because you know why? They
can't deal with logical arguments, bro.
And they're just going to start
insulting the prophet. That's where
they're going to go next. Yeah. You
think this isn't a big deal?
That nose is broke.
>> If defending Muhammad is too emotional
for you, you need to stop debating.
[music]
If you are this emotionally attached to
that man, Muhammad, you need to
re-evaluate yourself. I mean, this is
almost like a repeat of God Logic and
those guys at the Da'wah Booth in San
Diego. You guys need to calm So, sorry.
I'll just use a simple example to just
debunk this stupid claim. If I go to a
predominantly black area,
and I start insulting someone that they
love, arguments like Malcolm X, whoever,
okay? Whoever.
You have to be stupid to make this a
thing that's exclusive to Islam as if
Muslims are the only ones. Number one,
there is no evidence to suggest that
because they insulted the prophet,
that's what happened. There's no
evidence. I'm saying, if you go to any
If I go to the Bible Belt in in in in
Texas or wherever it is for that matter,
yeah? And I go to a hillbilly area, and
I start burning the Bible. Would they be
like, "You have right to freedom to
speech"? Brother, there'll be guns.
Right.
>> So, if you go to any neighborhood with
Latinos, you name it. It's common sense.
>> It is common sense that if you go and
start insulting people,
there's people There's some people who
are emotional. We might come and say
we're mature, whatever, get away. But
there are people that are not, from all
races and backgrounds. So, don't make
this an Islam thing, Live, okay?
Remember though, in Christianity, common
sense ain't too common.
So. I I I can't say anything to that,
bro. Real talk. down. It is not that
serious, all right? Have the
conversation because that's all people
are trying to have.
>> Bro, that's what Libyan I was saying.
Can we have a conversation conversation
conversation conversation conversation
Calm down. Calm down. Conversation. Yes?
So,
Live, thanks for speaking for us. I'm
not going to lie, you've really aided
our side.
The people listening are going to figure
out what's the truth themselves. And
I'mma be real. The more y'all keep
acting out like this and attacking and
then trying to act like you didn't do
it, it's on camera. It is on camera.
[laughter] You are right. It's on
camera.
>> camera. And you know what? It's not We
can't even say it's AI because it's your
own footage. Right.
>> So, thank you, Live. You guys cannot get
away with this stuff. It's on camera. We
see who was the aggressor. We see who
attacked first. We see who ruined this
entire setting. The Muslims. The
evidence speaks for itself.
Alhamdulillah, guys. We don't need to
say it was The evidence speaks for
itself. Not the Christians, okay? So,
y'all need to get yourselves together,
bro. If y'all want to really have real
honest conversations, you cannot
gaslight. You cannot project, especially
when it's on video.
>> It's top level projection.
>> tell you something, bro. I cannot agree
with him. I know he's right, bro. He
just He just summed it up because we
just brought the evidences and the
receipts. So, the manipulation, the
gaslighting, and who was it done by? The
Christians themselves. And not only
that, the clip from our side, bro, is
when I come I tell you, the Speakers'
Corner that I hear. Okay? Yeah. And that
is the reason why I don't go there. You
know what?
There's bad news. You know I had to
inform you before I even saw Chris
coming from the left. Okay, someone
attacking. So, in a nutshell, what we're
going to say is this. I know they're
going to try to take away from this and
try to avoid Libyano. Libyano's here.
Libyano is saying send me location. It's
as simple as that. Okay? And I'll be
honest with you, bro, this shows me
nothing but good news of the work that
you're doing. It's as simple as that. Do
you get what I'm trying to say? And we
ask Allah subhana wa ta'ala to protect
you, keep you in
a pure inshallah. Do you get what I'm
trying to say? It's as simple as that
because to me this kind of maneuver from
Chris that doesn't He doesn't really
behave. I've had a debate with him in
speakers' corner. He's not like that.
So, to see him like that, bro, whatever
you've done to him, it really bothered
him. And yeah, any last words, bro?
Uh yeah, so you know, my theory is that
he must have told somebody or consulted
some people before coming. And they must
have told him to act a specific way.
Because they told him, "Oh, maybe um
Libyano, he's going to get you with his
rhetoric. He's going to get you with
him being able to dominate a
conversation. So, you make sure you go
in there and be rude, loud, obnoxious.
Uh be aggressive and maybe it'll go
decent for you that way. But obviously,
it didn't work out." And if he didn't
have that agenda, he would not The first
thing he would not be like, "I challenge
you, you're running away." Where did you
even get that from? Do you get what I'm
trying to say? Like, where where would
you get that from? Uh it's
running away. He's never challenged me
to a debate. It shows you, bro, he
doesn't want to debate you. And this And
we've seen it We've seen it right
through you guys. And all we're going to
say is, guys, Libyano's here still in
London. Chris, please don't make these
silly excuses. And look, look, it's all
this facade that you've done, we've seen
right through it. The debate challenge
is there. If you genuinely want that
debate, send us location. That's all
we're going to say, inshallah, brothers
and sisters. We're going to carry on our
dawah. Our dawah is not going to stop.
And alhamdulillah, we have no problem
with Christians, Jews, Hindus, you name
it. Let's have a dialogue discussion. If
you want to come and stop our dawah, you
know what that shows? It shows you how
powerful our message is. And guess what?
We've had even this media admitting that
this is to show there's a 400% increase
in people coming to Islam because of the
whole Gaza situation. So, we understand
your pain. We understand your pain.
Till next time, brothers and sisters,
assalamualaikum warahmatullah
wabarakatuh. Please share this far and
wide so people can see the reality of
what really happened and what you heard
for yourself. We will physically fight
them here.
Goodbye.
This is One Ummah Sadaqah Jariyah video.
If you care about the dunya more than
akhirah, skip it. By one donation,
you're going to help 1.8 million people
in need. 551,000 people who have been
fed through the emergency food aid. You
are going to be sponsoring 4,200
orphans. You will be helping 250,000
people in Gaza. You'll be helping
123,000
people to be fed through our Qurbani
program. You will help feed 551,000
people through the emergency food aid.
56 masajids that are going to be built
around the world. And 74,000 given clean
safe water. That's why we want to keep
One Ummah 100% donation policy. And in
order for us to keep it 100, we need you
to help us by supporting this fund so
that all of the stuff that I mentioned,
you get the reward for every single one
of them. It's far more important than
the dunya. And you will see every penny
that you give on Yawm al-Qiyamah. The
decision is yours. The link is there.
Donate now.